[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
con la guerra en Ucrania la atención en
Europa se centró especialmente en las
consecuencias de dicho conflicto y para
nuestro interés en los refugiados que
salieron desde ese país en busca de
protección pero alrededor de Europa
otros grupos de solicitantes de asilo
siguen buscando ayuda belarús un Aliado
de Moscú ha permitido que cientos de
personas crucen hacia los estados
bálticos en un intento por convertirlos
en un arma de presión política así
llegan a naciones como letonia donde
apenas existe una cultura de integración
migratoria las enviadas de France 24
Irene sabio Leticia Álvarez investigaron
sobre la condición de estos solicitantes
de Refugio
poco antes de que los talibanes tomaran
el poder curar salió escapando de
Afganistán
hacete reunirse con nosotras en riga la
capital de letonia país en el que
ingresó tras un costoso viaje cuando Los
Traficantes lo abandonaron en vela ruso
no sabían prometido que nos llevarían a
algún lugar en Europa Pues nosotros
queríamos ir a Francia o Alemania pero
nos dejaron en la frontera entre
velarrus y letonia
curad nos muestra sus heridas cuenta que
cruzar la frontera fue una verdadera
pesadilla y cuando lo logró estuvo
detenido varios días por unos agentes no
identificados
nos trataban realmente mal nos
torturaron también con electrochoques la
directora de los Amaya gotabixne dice
que la prioridad de letonia es proteger
sus fronteras
los guardias de fronteras deben proteger
los confines letones es su trabajo
si las personas cruzan las fronteras
ilegalmente deben saber que eso correcto
la supuesta solidaridad del gobierno
Letón hacia los migrantes es difícil de
comprobar las autoridades dificultan el
acceso a los periodistas en las
estructuras de migrantes y los migrantes
dicen que no ven futuro en letonia este
es el caso de la Siria madre de dos
niñas pequeñas
tengo miedo Hemos llegado aquí con mucho
esfuerzo y tengo miedo que nos obliguen
a regresar
desde el año pasado los países bálticos
y Polonia acusan a ver a Rush de empujar
a los migrantes hacia sus fronteras
rojas siguen Buscando el sueño de una
vida mejor
para otros extranjeros letonia es el
país donde construyeron su vida pero
aunque llevan años recibiendo allí no
cuentan con la nacionalidad por
diferentes causas como apátridas no
cuentan con los mismos derechos de los
nacionales la historia es de Irene sabio
y Leticia Álvarez
Constantino es un fotógrafo de 28 años y
es uno de los más de 200 mil a patridas
que hay en letonia con el colapso de la
unión soviética su familia originaria de
Rusia perdió todo sus derechos políticos
y el heredó esta condición
no tengo derecho a ser policía bombero
parlamentario
Y si puedo ser miembro de un partido
político pero no ser el líder cuando lo
dices años Tuvo la oportunidad de tener
la nacionalidad letona la rechazó las
razones que no quiere perder los
privilegios que le otorga su estatus
como viajar sin visado Rusia
solo cambiaré de opinión Cuando el
estado Letón me pida perdón a mí a mi
familia y pida perdón por las leyes de
desnacionalización y por las leyes de
apátrida y por toda la situación sin
embargo el alcalde de riga afirma que su
país ha dado pasos hacia adelante
creo que esta situación se ha resuelto
aprobamos una ley para que todos los
recién nacidos ya no se hayan
considerados no ciudadanos
no lo vea Así dice que el idioma ruso
también está perdiendo espacios en la
sociedad letona
hace dos años se tomó la decisión
política de eliminar el ruso como
segundo idioma en las escuelas
que nació en Siberia y vive desde los 7
años en riga es una cuestión de
identidad
no tengo problemas emocionales pero si
tuviera que elegir entre los dos países
sería muy duro
una situación la de constantineluba aún
y resuelta que refleja la complicada
relación de Rusia con sus vecinos
recientemente el gobierno Letón dispuso
de un paquete de millones de euros para
ayudar a refugiados ucranianos pero
quedan miles pendientes por atender
letonia instaló una valla temporal en su
frontera con belarús para impedir el
paso de migrantes y los guardias
fronterizos usan la fuerza para
expulsarlos sin el debido proceso en
medio de una tensión con tintes
políticos estas personas siguen quedando
en el medio y sin respuestas hasta que
inmigrantes de France 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]